William Jefferson Clinton is the first
American president to have a chanted
family therapy sessions now he talks the
language of healing to America and to
the world but is it a serious
prescription can the Clintons man and
wife really reform a democracy where
money has talked so loud for so long can
they reconcile an insular isolationist
culture with the heritage of
intervention and the concept of the
superpower will bill be another
Roosevelt or just another fuzzy baby
boomer welcome to states of america
tonight in washington i hope to
scrutinize the new Clinton presidency
which promises a kickstart to a very
stalled American dream I've been most
fortunate with my guests Gary Hart a
distinguished former senator and twice
himself a presidential candidate might
with better fortune have been sitting
where mr. Clinton now sits Betsey Wright
was one of the president's campaign
managers and was for 12 years his chief
of staff in Arkansas she is a true F OB
or in the Washington vernacular a friend
of bills and VIN Weber is one of the
youngest men ever elected to Congress
where he worked for 12 years on the
Republican side of the aisle and was
widely considered one of the keenest
conservative political minds perhaps he
too is readying a bid for the White
House gentlemen and ma'am
thank you very much for joining me there
was something very odd about the opening
weeks of the presidency first there was
that encounter group session of Camp
David his first retreat where he said to
everyone present all his cabinet
officers let's all confide something
about each other I for example was too
fat when I was at school and felt bad
about it everyone you know relate and
tell something bad about themselves and
get in touch with your feelings and then
made his first if you will campaign and
issue of principle confrontation that
are from the sex life of soldiers
sailors and and airmen did this strike
any of you as a rum start to the
proceedings not from a Republican
standpoint it was a wonderful start to
the proceedings by I plants it started
out pretty silly and and I don't know
about his group encounter session with
the perspective cabinet but for a
candidate who had really done well
because of the perception correct or
incorrect
were narrowly focused on a social agenda
to initiate his administration with a
narrow issue on the social agenda was
just not very smart and I don't think it
served him well the first couple of
weeks were very rocky but I think the
reality of it is to make the transition
from campaign personnel to government
personnel and in fact that came the
transition from campaign to governing is
is much more different than many people
who've only worked in campaigns realize
and he began with a new team of people
who had not worked together before most
of which had never worked with him on a
daily basis before and what you call an
encounter session was a getting to know
each other outside of the immediate
pressures that began hitting them I
think that the questions of self
introspection were not his idea I think
that some facilitator came and thought
that that was a great idea facilitation
yes but Bill Clinton doesn't think
that's a bad idea I mean he likes people
talking about themselves this is a new
thing in his life
he didn't like talking about himself
until his brother's drug addiction came
to light and the the entire family began
searching for the base reasons for this
and he too went into a period of
introspection we'd had 12 years of
deferred a lot of social issues that
both President Reagan President Bush
refused to address one of those was the
question of the role of gays in our in
our national life at all levels and
anytime you you keep the stopper on a
boiling kettle whoever takes the stopper
off is going to get burned and that I
think it's to President Clinton's credit
that he addressed these issues some of
these issues in his campaign and to his
credit that he attempted to do something
about many of them all at once abortion
and gays in the military and variety of
other things it turns out that people in
the media like to focus on these issues
rather than the end of the Cold War
rather than the internationalization of
our economy rather than what I would
call the real structural problems and
that one didn't have much choice but to
focus on an issue the president a pitch
of Chosen I mean I'm I suppose I want to
move it up
a bit to me I chose that of them along
with a list of other issue but I mean
and it was it was emphasized in part
because the generational change that was
being tested by the media which is that
he is a president who did not himself
serve in the military about which a lot
was made during the campaign because of
his opposition to the policies in the
Vietnam well I'm glad you mentioned Oaks
I wanted to move the summing up a little
knowledge and make it as it were an
issue of courage when Ronald Reagan took
the earth or when George Bush took the
earth everyone could see straight away
they had an instinct for being called
commander-in-chief it's not magical they
overdid it nonetheless by taking that
earth Bill Clinton became
commander-in-chief he then seemed to
deal with the Armed Forces rather as if
they were another lobby or another group
to be dealt with pleased differences
split with them and so on do you do you
copy what I'm saying I don't I think
they're I think there were interpreters
or translators that that tried to make
that point it didn't come across that
way to me but I'm just ordinary citizen
well the policy changes that this
president is proposing some of which
would be proposed by a president of
either party and I'm thinking there are
defense spending levels but are gonna
put the military through a traumatic
experience I mean you know we're we're
still debating the question of gays in
the military but most people seem to
think that's a profound change in the
culture of the military maybe it's maybe
it's justifiable I'm not for it but it's
a change and the dramatic drawdown of
the defense budget is gonna put the
whole system through the wringer if you
will and so the question is at the end
of this process are we gonna have a
military that's capable of doing what
needs to be done in the 1990s or not and
as Senator Hart has already point out or
least alluded to the military's gonna
have a different function in the post
Cold War era to be sure it's something
we should talk about but if we're simply
gonna have a demoralized military that's
not good for this country and that's the
context in which candidate Clinton had
to address his own lack of military
background which is the same as my lack
of military background but I think it's
a it's a legitimate concern on the parts
of people who are wondering if we're
gonna have an effective military but let
me put you three issues of principle
that came up as campaign pledges that
would have been in the
days described as toughness issues
strength issues peace through strength
this is even requiring decision and
firmness Haiti Bosnia and the broadening
of the military to reflect as it were
the society from which it recruits and
there's been nothing heard of either if
these three promises that they alright
that's to say they've all three been
badly fudged in the early months of the
presidency does that not make one wonder
if who's in charge of the clattering
train what was the promise on Bosnia I
missed it promise on Bosnia was not to
stand by and let Serbia take over Bosnia
and expel the Muslim population by force
so he found indeed George Bush said it
was irresponsible it was it was flirting
with the suggestion of the use of force
and was roundly told no well that's what
we mean we mean that we can't let that
happen now they have let it happen the
same pledge was made about the refugees
in Haiti who as we speak browning in the
surf of Florida and that they would not
be treated as refuse than they are again
being treated and then there was two
ways of a pledge to quite a large
community that it also perhaps
coincidentally unlike the Haitians or
the Bosnians raised quite a lot of money
for the campaign the homosexual
community who are now being told well
it's lost in committee somewhere now
this isn't confidence-inspiring
i as the president's critic at this
table anyway I'd give him the benefit of
the doubt on a couple of those that
being gays in the military issue and the
Bosnia issue
I mean you view all of us who run for
office I understand you know you're
forced whether you want to or not to
take positions on everything in the
course of a campaign everything you have
no choice and then you get into office
and you sometimes realize that despite
your best efforts you weren't fully
aware of the circumstances so I I don't
fault him necessarily for a little
backtracking on Bosnia said something
any Democrat could say let me show sure
I think you can't clean itself all I'd
says the one that I miss really seems to
me to be worthy of criticism is Haiti
there's nothing in my view that the
president could have learned
subsequent to the election about Haiti
that he didn't know when he made that
promise and I said I was critical of
President Bush for his treatment of the
Haitians I think that is the one of
those three decisions that we ought to
look at and say it was this just a
cynical campaign pledge while I mean
what could you possibly have
and that caused you to back away from
that given the tremendous human toll of
your subsequent decision what are you
going to be out radical by congressman
webOS Anderson not at all but I but I
I'm not sure what profitably can be
added to what he said I have
particularly the first having been
through the experience one is called on
at least not to make a policy
declaration at least to make some
philosophical or personal a sentiment
about how you feel about things and
they're quite often translating those
sentiments to to actual concrete policy
turns out to be much much harder than
one well then can I put rephrase that
slightly feel that's your right
is this the character question that you
had to spend so much time on in the
campaign coming back again in office it
is not I think that we must recognize
the difference between a stated goal and
implementation and particularly when
you're dealing with the military you
have a very well entrenched traditional
industry and it takes a while to shift
it and we are watching an evolution of
the function of our military
unlike the congressman I'm not at all
worried about the strength that our
military will have under a Clinton
administration with the cutbacks I'm
because I know how committed he is to a
strong military that's appropriate for
this day and age but you don't just say
I want to do it you must move and change
major institutions in our society and
the military is one that quite rightly
is not quick to change but it's my
understanding that the incendiaries some
of the more labor-intensive bits of the
armed services that are being cut back I
mean if you look at it as an absolute
budget number the current proposal is
one it's thinkable a bush-quayle
administration could have asked Congress
to endorse in billions am I mistaken the
budget number that they've asked for yes
it gets thinkable that you're if you've
been returned that that's the sort of
figure you'd be playing they could sign
I think you know I think it's somewhat
below there's no argument though that a
Bush administration would have drawn
down the military budgets well and no
one looks at the end of the Cold War
so that doesn't change any of the
military realities in the world but
there are a couple of questions one is
how far do you go and I do think the
Clinton budget goes somewhat further
than President Bush would why don't we
go in a second is what does the Congress
then do to that budget I could even say
comfortably I think you could go to the
Clinton number on defense provided you
don't let Congress decide the priorities
in terms of domestic political
considerations but really addressing
what might be our new national security
considerations unfortunately in a
democracy things are not going to work
that way okay isn't this their the kind
of rhetoric that you get when party
allegiance is a fairly vestige you'll
think in people's lives I mean there's
been a considerable decline in the way
people identify and register as
committed members of party hasn't there
well I think the decline of the party is
a serious problem and I'm not sure that
you can attribute it just to any one
cause but certainly at the height of
perrault's popularity in the in the
spring and early summer late late spring
let's say of 1992 70% of American people
told I believe the Wall Street Journal
that they had no confidence in either
political party that's a remarkable
thing and it's very bad thing for our
system of democracy that's your ID you
think that's fair this does the
democratic party not still champion the
poor and the it does but I don't think
there's the kind of communication
between the party and the people that it
champions that there used to be your
needs to be I'm a strong advocate of
political parties I think they've served
this country well in its history and
basically they have served it by keeping
stuff out of the back rooms and I think
that what we need is a new concept of of
political parties and what they can be
in the 90s I think that they can be
critical to cutting back on the amount
of money needed to spent in campaigns
and economizing in campaigns I think
that they should take a role of holding
their own office holders accountable for
a performance and connections to the
people I I am an advocate of reform of
the parties but I am very strongly an
advocate of restraining the parties both
of them because we need each other in
this country to keep each other more
focused well isn't that in fact God just
what a lot of people feel when they look
at Washington they think actually it's a
one-party state where the two parties
wash each other's hands if you remember
the great scandal of the ages was the
Savings and Loan
de Baca for whichever one is still
paying there was a other kinds of
interest groups there's there's real
important distinction to make there yes
Washington should be criticized for
policies which strengthen incumbency
without regard to party but that's not
the same saying the two parties are
strengthening each other we have seen a
decline of parties partly because
incumbents on both parties have
strengthened themselves to the point
that they don't need parties I agree
very much with Betsy I want to see
parties hold their elected officials
considerably more accountable than they
do today but that means you have to have
stronger parties and in a sense weaker
incumbents what about the idea of the
imperial presidency that the President
himself very very quickly becomes
insulated from all these domestic and
popular pressures that he can run a
state within a state I don't think so I
think this is the society generally in
the country has gotten to be a bigger
and more complex and clearly much more
complicated than it was 100 or even 50
years ago but 20 years ago for that
matter but seeing the president pension
during his town meetings and trying
which of course we know he's trying to
do to do an end run around the around
the press and speak to people directly
right isn't there something so slightly
plaintive don't you feel what he gets up
on the stage of says please no dead lose
touch with me I'm being drawn into the
White House and away from my roots but
that's partly if that's a product of a
lot of factors not the least of which as
we tend to take shots at our leaders
over here so they have to be protected
protection gets into motorcades and and
isolation in the White House and I think
he's trying desperately to break out of
that well he were a friend of Bill so I
mean do you feel that he's in any danger
of getting cut off from the folk from
whence he came I don't because he is
determined that he won't be and he's
very sensitive about it this is a man
who is addicted to meeting new people
every day and he will have to find ways
to constantly be interacting with people
I do want to take issue with you're
saying he doesn't end run around the
press and goes directly to the people he
goes directly to the people as well as
talking to the press so varied approach
on which to take our break which will be
shorter after which we'll return to the
penton's
and to their works join us
welcome back to States of America and to
Washington where we're debating the
Clinton presidency I thought in this
segment we might try and forget we were
in Washington in fact and transcend our
sort of Co membership in the political
journalistic class and just think about
what America is up against as a standard
of comparison I mean consider the fact
that it's become a destination a net
detonation you know on really quite a
colossal scale look at the the lost
generation of alienated American youth
at the decay and collapse of the cities
the the apparent loss of competitive
edge in economic innovation these are
pretty awesome things are they not Betsy
Ryan do you think the president really
wakes up every morning aware of this I
think he wakes up I think he goes to
sleep aware of it and I also think that
we are at a point of both optimism in
our country and opportunity to reverse
that cynicism to reverse that decay that
we haven't had for a long time there is
a spirit of Hope across this country it
is probably both the greatest challenge
in the greatest enemy that Bill Clinton
has is fulfilling the expectations of
that hope but it has given us a spirit
in this country that's wonderful but
does the small town called Hope which
I'll be your pardon me was saying we've
heard about before and then there are
quite big towns like Los Angeles and New
York and Chicago where there's basically
racial and social mayhem impending I
mean how long are you going to say that
it's a matter of the spirit at which you
approach it what are you going to do I
contend that there is a spirit of Hope
in those places right now also and there
they there is a sense that we may get
our act together in this country that
hasn't been there in a long time they
thought she was a major difference again
as the end of the Cold War we our
priorities in this country for half
century were were oriented towards
stopping communism and our highest
priority was to finance that effort and
that necessarily detracted politically
and economically from the domestic
agenda if you will both so social agenda
economic agenda I am a student of Arthur
Schlessinger juniors thesis of cycles of
American history
we have deferred for at least one cycle
of not to major reforms in our society
and many of them have resulted in the
consequences you've stated President
Clinton's challenge now isn't the
gays-in-the-military with all due
respect to him and them his issue is to
restructure the fundamental structures
of this country its military structures
its financial structures its social
structures whatever you press through
that well known as no one's had that
challenge since Franklin Roosevelt and
so he's got to think big
very very big well can I press you to
give either of you any of you actually
have press concentrate on the two
Democrats for the Oh permission Congress
I'm just at the moment could I press you
just to give the shining instance of the
the process begun oh the process it's
begun process that's begun the
president's economic package which
attacks both the deficit and creation of
new jobs simultaneously and I need to
say to attack the creation of new jobs I
know
no no attacks thank you very much right
in there which process attacks the
deficit and and would create new jobs
and stimulate the economy simultaneously
and also trying to prepare a major
healthcare reform in this country you
can only move in a big way on so many
fronts and those are very big fronts and
they happen to be ones that I think will
go right to the core of the problems
creating our cynicism in our decades a
toy of cynicism you must be feeling
fairly embittered congressman because
I'll throw back in the fall I remember
you saying and you and your contraire
the economy is about to go into a bit of
an upswing probably maybe in time for
November and Bill Clinton will raise
taxes on middle class now actually
around January the economy went into
business we and then President Clinton
said he'd raise taxes on the middle
class very very sad for you to have to
watch this as a spy changer well not not
yes but on the other hand I also as one
who said for four years of the Bush
administration we needed to be doing
more to maximize economic growth rate so
I criticize President Clinton for saying
on our economy was the worst since the
depression which was a massive massive
exaggeration but clearly we could do
better than we've been doing the last
four years I don't argue that I simply
are you still an economic program but as
premise much as your question was on the
notion that the American economy is a
basket case is simply based on a false
foundation during the much despised
1980s the United States took the lead in
just about every new technology coming
online number one in cellular telephones
number one in fiber optics number one in
computers number one in computer chips I
don't say this is the end-all of the
discussion but the notion that we'd
simply slipped into the bog in the 80s
it's simply not true the more important
question in my view is why not just in
the 80s but if you track social
indicators back to the early 1960s why
haven't we been successful in dealing
with the problems of those people that
we talked about in East LA or any of the
other poor neighborhoods in the country
despite spending trillions of dollars
through programs put on the books in the
nineteen sixties at the time of the
Great Society no question for you then I
think the conditions in LA would be a
lot worse today without them default the
programs for not solving every social
ill this is the point without those
programs without some social commitment
to justice economic and legal justice in
this country I think this country would
have gone into flames as it started to
do in 68 those programs like that gave
people hope and promise they didn't
solve everybody's problems now the
question is what do we do now
the supply-side experiment experiment
has failed I think at the cost of three
trillion dollars in debt since it was
tried and now we've got to go back to
try some other things I think it's a
mixed economy of government intervention
and management and stimulation of the
private sector we have a cabinet now
that has as many millionaires in it as
Bush's tyrannous Reagan's did have a
cabinet of composed of people who have
been very largely insulated from all of
this so part of the let's say the more
fortunate if not the more skillful class
and by what right do they presume to say
that they feel the page John Kennedy was
rich man Franklin Roosevelt was a rich
man that's got nothing to do with it you
don't have to be impoverished to
understand poverty we're to love people
and that's one of the big differences
between the Democrats he named and the
Republicans that we've had most recently
and certainly I think it's one of the
strongest people I mean with all due
respect to your gentleness here what you
just said in laying out the
technological advances is my nightmare
is a Democrat because it absolutely
ignores the declining quality of life
for the individuals in this country by
the millions which occurred during their
period of time and animation that can be
proud of technological advances and not
care about what's happening to the
working force and the quality of life
that people are leaving is a sick nation
this is my congressman your chance to
show you or beat your people this is my
concern for the Democrats when I
described being becoming number one in
computers fiber optic cellular
telephones computer chips it somehow is
lost on my Democrat friends that all
those things that turned into millions
of jobs for people that's how you create
jobs this administration does not seem
to understand it Betsy doesn't surprise
me that it would be sort of lost and you
almost terrified beauty on the talk
about the create jobs but this
administration does understand it but
this administration measures the
economic health based not only on those
factors but also on what is happening to
our people and you left it at those
technological advances and did not go
and look at what has happened to the
declining incomes of the American people
the the abilities to be covered by
health insurance I don't think that you
can define the American economy without
doing both I I think that you should do
both as well but I came back to the
point
Guerry a few minutes ago what are we
seeing new out of this administration to
attack these problems I'm not arguing
Gary back to your point that spending
money on social programs is per se a bad
thing maybe some Republicans but that's
not what I'm saying but I am saying
we've got a 30-year experiment at least
that we can look at and certainly nobody
is going to say that those programs have
been monumentally successful now let's
put aside the question of levels of
spending for a minute about which which
I think can become a distraction
shouldn't we be talking about changing
the way that those programs deliver
those services
I may have to recover the authority of
the chair disposition Jones I remember
in the in the not just the closing but
the opening stages of the campaign that
it was governor Clinton as he was who
was a rather more strident than the
Republican Party about the need to get
the poor people to pull up their socks
and generally pull their weight and
welfare reform and in fact saying I
remember this very clearly in the last
month of their campaign those who do not
work should not eat one of st. Paul's
harshest statements later elaborated by
Lenin into a remote for the class war
this didn't strike me as that
particularly shall we say has long been
an advocate of welfare reform and those
programs were enormous ly successful
what failed about those programs was our
inability to adapt them to a changing
world of where the recipients got
information to the basic structures that
were changing in their communities and
welfare reform is a prime example of how
you take those programs and adapt them
to the current lives that people are
living and we will see a lot more of
them and Bill Clinton will exhibit
leadership with both the Democrats and
the Republicans in Congress to make
those team but really if since you were
taking them through high morale line
about the lives of the poor incivil you
remember when the Lady Bracknell says in
The Importance of Being Earnest and
what's the use of the poor people if
they don't set a good example
no one says in America that rich people
have to lead exemplary lives and prove
that they've earned their money and
being vigilant by sociologists and
talking about the poor people I was
talking about the middle-class with
declining incomes and declining quality
of life and declining health coverage I
mean we were even losing our
middle-class during this here's my
chance to ask you not true here's my
chance to ask you in what in what
bracket does the middle class exist
financial income bracket in the
Democratic imagination now because there
really is some difficulty we're all
finding in in getting this definition
you can make it a bullpup racket but I
would be grateful I'm gonna back off
from doing that social logic question
what profiting what I mean so what well
it's whatever the longer since it was
attacked what it was excuse me
essentially it was a fiscal question in
the election it was we weren't raised
your taxes if you're middle class which
must mean there's a median of income it
raises the real definition of middle
classes if you believe that you can move
up if you if you believe you can move up
your middle class in this country just
about wherever your income falls the
people that are not middle class are
those that are sort of like terrified of
falling back you can feel the pearls
snapping I don't think by the way you
disagree with it if you think about the
people that are really not as little
class this country are people that are
in such despair they don't think they
can never move from where they are if
someone has hoped that through through
some kind of effort they can better
themselves economically they really
adapt to a whole range of middle-class
attitudes and cultural norms in this
country and and that's that is a better
definition of middle class than then
twenty thousand dollars a year income
which is where the clinton people seem
to parties but unlike Gretl of other
developed capitalist countries such as
Japan Germany even Britain which is
relatively poor compared United States
the unites the Unites States appears to
have a permanent underclass the class of
people who don't vote can barely read as
you say find it very difficult to move
to be mobile in labor are usually if
it's a darker skin than the majority of
the population and who are very
combustible socially or at least are
believed to be if not socially then in
criminal terms often one by one or group
by group gang by gang now why should it
be assumed as it seems to be in the
political discourse that I hear that
somehow a given fact I don't hear any
talk about changing that at all
well that's that's wrong I mean if if
your description is accurate that's very
very wrong you mean it would be it would
be an awful thing to be true or it's
wrong of me to say sir I this is the
former good I think you're wrong those
say so I think there isn't even about
what to do with these so-called on night
one very much so and one of throughout
the campaign one of the things that Bill
Clinton talked about was to make it a
country where every person could be
everything that he or she wanted to be
but was a restraint Ronald Reagan was
capable of saying that and did well Bill
Clinton has done you do it president a
very short movie and and it's also
really believing it and Bill Clinton has
a longtime record with the Governors
Association of of outlining what these
barriers are which have to do with the
the breakdown of community and the
breakdown of family and the the new role
that schools play and and the the
declining health of our children and the
stopping the teen pregnancy stopping the
the the aids threat that's now going on
with so many young people in those
communities you just described
congressman Webb was party at any race
took the view that probably Democratic
solutions had helped to create that I
mean there's all the sixties immorality
and dissolution of traditional ties was
responsible for the technology do you
take that well I think we take the view
that social welfare programs well
intentioned did not succeed and had some
negative consequences and you don't need
to look to only to Republicans look at
back of the things that Senator Moynihan
was talking about as far back as the
1960s no neither party comes to this
debate with a whole lot to brag about in
my view if I'm sort of forced to defend
my party I'm gonna be quick to attack
the Democrats as a good strategy but my
point would be neither party in my view
has dealt very effectively with the
problems of the poor for a long time
I'll start by taking my hat off to the
people in the 60s that divides the Great
Society cuz they clearly cared about it
they thought a whole great a whole deal
about I don't think many people on
either party have invested similar
amounts of intellectual energy in the
problems of the poor since then and
that's that's my concern
Oh cousin hates me but I think it's true
it's true
but I liked the way that you said it
would be wrong you know I want you I
want you to elaborate about that if we
give up I mean if regardless a party if
nation we give up on the 20% who are
below the standard of any decent
standard of living would you raise it a
stretchy percent well I don't know pick
a number whatever the number is if it's
3% if we give up as a society in a
country then we demean ourselves and
that corrodes our spirit in a whole lot
of ways that none of us serve our I mean
the fact that we have treated I don't
want to get on a like a Oscar soapbox
here but the way we've treated the
Americans the Native Americans in this
country for a couple of hundred years
the fact we didn't address a fundamental
racism until 20 or 30 years ago
I think that's corrosive I think it gets
into the soul of a society and the issue
of justice the older I get anyway is the
central issue of a society and we as
Democrats criticize our opponents
because we think or we say that we think
they don't care they don't evidence a
that commitment to justice really tell
me we fumble we enact programs people
have to pay tax dollars but as Franklin
Roosevelt said the the a there's a
different scale for the warm-hearted
versus the cold-hearted and that's what
it's all about I was going to give you
20 seconds to reply to that congressman
but I decided it would be unfair in any
way of the chill wind of economic
reality bears on that's too old we have
to take another break I've got two real
talking subjects when we come back which
like General MacArthur we certainly
shall join us
welcome back to states of america where
i'm scrutinizing the Clinton presidency
with Gary Hart
Betsy Wright and VIN Weber I thought we
might talk about the other kinds of
division in America we've talked about
the social and racial ones a bit but
there's a a cultural divide or series of
divisions more properly some core to
return to ghettoization people defining
themselves as gay American let's say or
Spanish American or African American and
we're there for politics has to take
account of this I was very struck by the
way that President Clinton when he was
appointing his cabinet said I'm against
bean-counting as he called it while
apparently being quite a deaf little
counter of beans and making sure there
was something for everybody is this do
you think the American Way do you think
it's it's wise to have a spoil system of
this sort well you know you can
overstate the change there there's been
a certain amount of what you might call
bean-counting for a long time in
politics I do think that they've taken
it to an extreme in this administration
but past administrations particularly
the Democratic Party which has been a
more coalition building party than
Republicans you know they're a certain
number of seats in various parts of
government for Irishmen and for Jews and
for Italians and and by and large we all
thought of that it's pretty good that's
the way that people moved out of the
lower class or underclass and into
established role models to move up in
society the question is how rigorously
do you apply that model some of us look
at the Clinton administration we say a
bit too rigorously if we're going to try
to directly mirror the population
without regard to married you're going
to end up with some people who should be
able to serve in government thrown aside
because they're white males with an
ankle saxon background in other words
it's a question of recognizing the
people are such as it's a matter of
denomination it's a matter of you know
government should make some kind of an
effort to include people that have been
left out of society how rigorously do
you do that and how many people that are
of great ability are you going to
exclude from government because they are
not female or Hispanic or black that's
the question
do you I don't think you need me to
rephrase the question
oh I don't we we have had 12 years now a
very rigorous condescension about
minorities and women in this country
from the leadership in the White House
and we have a lot of ground to make up
breaking new ground forth for power
positions for women and minorities is
not easy and it is not done without
clumsy awkward stumbling and we have
seen some of that the issue is not being
counting the issue is not what kinds of
beans are in the pot the issue is
whether you consider all kinds of people
for all kinds of leadership positions
and diversity I think we had a really
hard time getting the American people on
the course of understanding what
diversity was because of some of the
awkward stumbling this is not an easy
thing to do and a determination to
demonstrate that among the best minds in
this country on all issues are white men
as well as women and minorities is not
easy and I commend the president for
taking the risk and making the effort
even for the stumbling that has occurred
particularly in the Attorney General
position no president anglo-saxon which
is a for the origin of wasp Murray I
mean I'm in a position to say this if I
look at Vera and Jordan is black
American african-american Ron Brown
black American African to distinguished
Clinton appointments and it's very bad
who's the woman what I really see is
what they have in common that I that I
don't have in common with them and it's
not my skin color or my sex it's the
fact that I'm not a member of the class
of corporate lobbyists and and lawyers I
mean in other words I want to ask you
the question pluralism for whom who's
supposed to be impressed by this kind of
allocation of seating around the cabinet
table well I mean you're also gonna have
to look at more members of the cabinet
with Henry Cisneros and with Donna
Shalala and and secretary Payne you know
I mean I
rich people are part of this society too
and they are not monolithic either
they've been the only ones recognized
and so for you to come back and say well
you've got some too
we we have a lot of people who aren't
rich also and again that's diversity and
you're you're only picking one piece of
it and it's the totality of it I mean
listen no one woman represents all women
in this country in fact women will not
be equal in this country until it is
okay for us to be different from each
other and we have to recognize that
among ourselves too so no one woman
selected as Attorney General or as
Secretary of Energy is like all women
but but they do demonstrate that among
the experts and leaders in this country
on in those areas are women senator Lee
who looks as if you were about to break
in there no I doesn't strike you as
although the 13 million as I believe is
13 earners in the company I I think it
it's kind of an irrelevant debate but it
it is somewhat important how how one got
to be a millionaire if you inherited it
generally you have one set of views if
you had to earn earn it and work for it
you've probably and you started at a
fairly low level you probably have a
different set of views but that's I
don't know what that proves regarding
anything we're talking about here well
what would the stay without sums of
money but moving quite abruptly to
another subject it's been announced that
anything between 1.7 and decoite some
figures 3.2 billion American dollars are
kind of give it to the restitution of
the former Soviet Union in particular to
Russia and it also seems the president
trims him there he very often wants to
be on both sides of many questions and
despair the difference he's of
absolutely one mind on one thing which
is that Boris Yeltsin is in a sense his
man do you think we've over invested so
not in the future of one foreign
politician perhaps we have right the two
observations I would make is first of
all
having been back and forth to the former
Soviet Union and Russia a lot I can
remember three or four years in which
people said will Gorbachev succeed and
we personalized this revolution I think
we're making to a degree the same
mistake with Boris Yeltsin I think it
would be wrong to to put all of our eggs
in one basket if you will he is the
dominant reform Democrat there is no one
else on the horizon that I know of to
replace him and therefore he deserves
our support but we shouldn't be so
fixated on him that we missed the point
that a fundamental revolution is
occurring in Russia and will continue to
occur for 20 or 30 years it's not going
to be solved tomorrow the second thing I
would say is I think there are a variety
of ways and I hope President Clinton
will adopt them eventually soon to help
the Russians in the Commonwealth states
that are if you will off budget for
example a system of loan guarantees we
could adopt a we could create a program
something similar to our so-called
Fannie Mae or Ginnie Mae which would
create new financing mechanisms for
Western corporations and American
corporations investing in infrastructure
projects in Russia that would not impact
on the federal budget deferred taxation
on income received over there
elimination of the last vestiges of
cocom which is a restriction on
technology transfer which some of us
have been trying to get I don't want to
cut you short on this I don't need to
become too long of a wishlist is it what
I mean well question is still appointed
you think this is congruent with what
appears to be a very very heavily
weighted insistence on the on the
political character and survival of
Boris Yeltsin probably too much but on
the other hand there is no one else but
there is a vote coming up and they
apparently the only way to vote for or
against reform centers around for
against Boris Yeltsin is I think
President Clinton in his earlier
statements was very clear to support the
the reform movement and democracy on
behalf of this country but since that
time a vote has been set and I think
that that has a lot to do with the
strong support for the man it goes to
the question doesn't it also if America
as a desert country after all the
majority of the Russian debt is actually
held by Germany
so that a Clinton policy on Russia to
succeed must ask other people's money to
be spent so I don't know whether you
agree with this enormous remember that
were judges to the question of the
relationship between the economic and
the foreign dimension well I first of
all I think President Clinton is right
on target is handling a Biltz and I'm
I'm proud of it as an American I think I
hope my party is supportive when it
comes to the Congress and you have to
actually put up the dollars there are
more things that you can do which is not
meant to be critical of the 1.6 billion
but I agree with everything senator Hart
talked about I also think we need to
look hard at trading relationships with
those countries if capitalism is going
to take root in Eastern Europe they're
gonna have some have to have someone to
sell things to and we can create markets
for them right here but that again
impacts on a domestic economy I think we
should do it I would open up our trading
relationships with Eastern Europe and
the former Soviet Union as quickly and
as liberally as we possibly could but
that will be debate in the south I
suppose and that one pretty footnote I
think we've made a mistake for the last
several years of defining democracy in
economic terms that is to say we've
we've tended the previous administration
particularly to to gauge the progress of
democracy and Russia and elsewhere based
on their willingness to accept
capitalist market economics those are
two different concepts frankly and I
think you can have capitalism without
having democracy I don't think you can
have democracy without also then having
open markets so I think we ought to put
our eggs in the democracy basket not in
the capitalist basket because one
doesn't mean that that doesn't guarantee
markers on the assuit democracy both you
gentlemen found in the end experience of
Congress a rather unsatisfying one found
the word often used in Washington I
think it's leaked into the European
press tourism gridlock in other words
the sense that nothing can get done you
have to spend too much time raising
money that the lobbyists controlled too
much and so on does it depress you that
President Clinton seems to rely rather a
lot for his congressional management on
some of the old committee chairmen
dinosaurs on all the business as usual
well the choice does it have yeah I'd
love to blame him for that I don't think
you can hardly fault him for that I
think the Congress has to look itself in
the mirror
look at in the face a lot closer I don't
fault this president of the previous one
but the notion of Congress as a
full-time lifelong career is bad for the
country bad for the institution and I
would go a separate so it's bad for the
individuals that are serving there and
I've been sitting Gary I couldn't agree
more my generation what many of us got
into politics as a an expression of
citizen commitment if he will part-time
almost idealistic grecian gonna
contribute a contribution to your
society but I in the course of my 20
years 15 or 20 years I saw the whole
process become very careerist oriented
most political parties now you have
people coming here the age of 27 28 and
they they tilt almost everything towards
staying as long as they can in
government and I think that's bad it's a
question I want you to generalize a bit
to transparency ROG about it it's clear
from this discussion lots of others that
are going on in Washington the moment
that an enormous amount is invested in
the idea of Clinton's success and
therefore that if there is a failure
there's a correspondingly huge potential
for disillusionment and for cynicism and
perhaps for people really giving up on a
Democratic idea do you feel that danger
as you as you watch them well first of
all there isn't going to be a failure
that but the real point you're asking is
how will his successes be translated to
the American people and Bill Clinton
learned many years ago that you must
keep the people informed of the changes
you were making as you go along not
after they have happened and and we are
seeing a president who's using
communications technology and access to
the people far beyond that which has
been used in the past for that very
reason the success with which he
mobilized support of giving his economic
plan and proposal a try was was one
example but we will soon see an all-out
effort on the health care proposal when
it is formulated and I know this is
consistent with the way he governed in
Arkansas did you take it to the people -
not just the folks that vote in the
Congress now the healthcare proposal
raises the very point I was come to
which is the question of the status and
potency of the first lady some people
say that never mind how good the first
lady is she has to bear in mind not just
that she wasn't elected but that she
can't be fired and thus certain decorum
has to be expected do you think that's a
sexist statement I certainly do people
people didn't worry about John Kennedy
not firing Bobby Kennedy and that isn't
to say that they're not really
prohibited works afterwards but that it
wasn't because he couldn't fire him and
that goes to a question about what their
relationship is and they they can differ
and I what I wish that people knew about
their relationship that I know is the
professional respect that they have for
each other's roles and responsibilities
and Hillary will be forever mindful that
he is the president and is ultimately
his responsibility to make the decisions
and she will try to help him succeed on
that I find that many of the questions
about the propriety of her role and a
major policy issue like health to be
really thinly veiled curiosity on the
part of men about this fundamental
decision Bill Clinton made to marry a
woman this smart and this strong and
that it's really a curiosity about Bill
not about her but the curiosity will
turn to much more politicized
Inquisition if a health care plan turns
out to be a turkey plan she is directing
a task force which will make a
recommendation to him he has always
altered her task force recommendations
to some degree or another so he will
then make it his and she will help him
with whatever form he takes it forth in
but it will be his health care plan not
hers that returns us in a way in
properties where Brenda where we began
which is on the question of character
and I hope you won't mind if I take
advantage of having both UN senator Hart
here to ask this question during the
campaign you were subjected to a lot of
innuendo about the president sex life a
new Senator know what it is like to be
accused of being sexually indiscreet
when you're trying to run a
seneschal campaign do you think this
shows American Puritanism and American
hypocrisy or do you think it shows that
one needs a certain type of person to
run for the highest office no comment on
my partner no comment from the senator
okay by all means come I think it shows
that the media is no longer respecting
in any degree of the privacy of people
who run for office and they no longer
able to make real judgments about when a
politician's personal life might affect
his public performance and that that I
think that's terribly unfortunate
whether the politicians involve the
Republicans are Denham very quickly
though the Ronald Reagan night a woman
won chosen myself and don't you wish you
had a bit more about how they were
getting along no I I think you're
missing the point here about the issues
that came up in the Clinton campaign far
more than Senator hearts campaigns
though it it laid the groundwork for a
generational change and that any time we
were going to be considering a nominee
for president of this country who grew
up in the 60s I have to cut you off I'm
frightfully sorry it would happen just
like this the sands of time have
insensitively run out on us and I'd like
to thank Gary Hart very much and Betsy
Wright and VIN Weber for shedding light
and even little heat on the Clinton
presidency for now good night